former bachelor star Nikki Farrell gets
engaged
who needs a rose when you can marry your
best friend the 29 year olds who won
Juan Pablo galavis his controversial
season took to Instagram on Monday to
announce the happy news of her
engagement to Tyler van Lew writing and
on the last day of vacation this
happened I can't wait to marry my best
friend over the moon happy right now
leading up to the big proposal the
blonde beauty shared pics of their
winter vacation Colorado captioning this
ski shot a little New Year's Eve
snowshoeing through the San Juan
National Forest with my favorite snow
bunny hashtag winter wonderland hashtag
Happy New Year while it's unclear how
long they've been an item the reality
star has been sharing pics of the two
hanging out and traveling together for
the last six months Nicki's happily ever
after comes over a year after she split
from Juan Pablo the bachelor who refused
to say I love you having ham in a bucket
and I'm gonna use it I'm not a hundred
percent sure they don't want to propose
to you the two dated for just seven
months but now it looks like she's met
her perfect match hashtag
you